bonsoir
rien ne résiste à la bienveillance
retenait alors je vais vous dire à 21
non je pousse la porte du service des
remèdes pédiatrique du chr de lille j'y
découvre deux choses 1
l'amour puisque j'y rencontre mon mari
qui était apprenti médecins dans ce
service de la souffrance j'étais donc
dans un service d'un bateau pédiatrique
ça veut dire qu'on y recevait des
enfants et des pré adolescents touchés
par des maladies comme l'eczéma la
dermatite atopique
le psoriasis une souffrance terrible
regarder un petit peu ce que peut-être
l'état d'une peau qui est complètement
les haies et je pense que c'est
important de dire à ce moment là peu
lent la peau c'est son enveloppe c'est
l'image que l'on donne de soi et dans ce
service
j'ai rencontré des enfants qui étaient
exclus du monde scolaire qu'on ne
touchait plus qu'on embrassait plus tout
simplement parce qu'ils avaient une peau
qui était extrêmement abîmées je m'en
souviendrai absolument toute ma vie à 37
ans je fais un petit virage je dis bien
un petit virage parce que je reste quand
même marqué par les relations les airs
les ressources humaines des relations
humaines
je me suis rendu compte que de toute
façon quelques individus qu'ils qu'il
soit il apporte toujours quelque chose à
l'autre et ça c'est un une partie de ma
vie qui a été extrêmement important
parce que j'ai aidé des gens à rester
debout des gens à croire qu'il était
possible de faire autrement
à 45 ans j'ai pensé que dans trois têtes
il y avait plus de choses que dans une
haie forte de ce constat que vous avez
sûrement tous fait je me suis dit hé
bien dans ce cas là il est peut être
important de construire collectivement
quelque chose et j'ai mis en place un
réseau d'entreprises textiles
alors si j'en parle c'est
parce que c'est important dans le
déroulement des choses c'est que
collectivement bien sûr on l'a mis en
place des actions commerciales on a mis
en place une greffe une réflexion sur
les ressources humaines
c'était le moment des 35 heures mais on
a surtout mis en place une réflexion sur
la recherche et le développement
parce que c'est important dans le
textile de faire autre chose que ce
qu'on faisait il y a dix ou quinze ans
ou 20 ans à cinquante trois ans il
s'avère que j'étais toujours dans ce
réseau est dans le cadre de la recherche
et développement je participe à un
séminaire à l'école d'ingénieurs
textiles sur les textiles techniques et
une ingénieure nous informe que
aujourd'hui on pouvait filer des métaux
précieux comme l'or l'argent le cuivre
et elle nous donne les principes actifs
de l'argent alors je ne sais pas si ça
vous est déjà arrivé mais moi dans ma
tête ça fait une connexion et je me suis
dit hé bien tous ces gens qui avaient
des problèmes au niveau de la peau je
sais que l'argent et antibactérien
anti-inflammatoires cicatrisant
peut-être que je pourrais faire quelque
chose pour pouvoir soulager ces gens que
j'ai rencontrés il ya déjà quelques
années et ben j'ai donc décidé de après
qu'elle mais dit avoir plus exactement à
l'occasion de ce séminaire donc je
rencontre cet ingénieur je vais la voir
a dit sue de la présentation qu'elle
fait et je lui dis pensez vous que si
j'associe ce fils d'argent avec un autre
fils pour pouvoir constituer un grand
pansement pour moi dans ma tête c'était
un grand pansement pour les peaux les et
ça pourrait marcher et elle me dit si
vous ne le faites pas vous ne le saurai
jamais donc c'est un défi qu'elle me
lancer et je me suis dit c'est trop bête
de ne pas y aller
et donc je décide très vite de déposer à
l'inpi une enveloppe soleau pour
protéger mon idée est ce qui me semble
aussi un
hortense et que deux mois après je suis
licenciée pour raison économique
alors là je me dis bon qu'est ce que je
fais vous savez c'est toujours difficile
vous vous dites bien sûr je pourrais
avancé sur mon projet je pourrais faire
quelque chose mais j'étais encore maman
avec des enfants à charge
bon me suis dit après tout à un
troisième cycle de ressources humaines
peut-être que tu peux essayer de trouver
du boulot je vais essayer on m'a dit non
madame ce n'est plus possible
donc je me suis dit bon qu'est ce que je
vais faire
et ben voilà un jour on m'a même dit
vous êtes compétentes métro ag donc je
cherche toujours et puis je me dis eh
bien j'ai plutôt l'opportunité de
reprendre un commerce dans le viol il
alors je me dis bon bain allons-y
puisque il faut quand même que je trouve
quelque chose pour subsister et surtout
aider mes enfants je me mets dans ce
commerce
et figurez vous que je crois que là
c'est quand même un signe le plafond de
nos magasins me tombe sur la tête 18
mois après avoir commencé je me suis dit
quand même ça fait trois fois ma belle
ce serait peut-être bien que tu penses
vraiment sur ton projet puisque tu l'as
tu l'as dans la tête et donc je décide
de présenter mon dossier à l'incubateur
d'innovation textile de roubaix pour
pouvoir être accueillis et accompagnés
pendant un certain nombre de temps au
pouvoir développer mon projet donc comme
vous le voyez je m'appuie sur i know
texte je m'appuie sur le centre européen
des textiles innovants et j'avance et
donc à 60 ans je décide de créer mon
entreprise
parce que pendant les quatre années qui
s'était écoulé j'avais pu faire la
preuve du concept que le fait d'associer
un fils d'argent avec un fil de coton me
permettez de faire des vêtements de
corps qui soulagé
les patients qui souffraient
d'affections dermatologiques et la
boucle est bouclée puisque comme je
voulais 10 à 21 ans je démarre dans un
service dermato pédiatrique et à 60 ans
je m'occupe effectivement de travailler
sur une solution textile innovantes qui
permettent de soulager les personnes et
surtout qu'ils soient naturels et non
invasive et qui permettent aux gens de
d'alterner avec des traitement à la
cortisone et ça je crois que c'est de la
bienveillance et puis donc voilà je crée
mon l'entreprise et puis bien sûr je ne
gomme pas les souffrances mais je
soulage et je pense que vraiment ça
c'est ce qui est le plus important pour
moi et j'espère en tout cas que au
travers de ce que j'ai pu vous présenter
très rapidement vous avez pu comprendre
que 1
il faut de la persévérance de il faut de
la confiance en soi
3 je pense que quand j'en aurai 70 c'est
pas tout de suite mais quand on l'aurait
70 je serais heureuse d'avoir fait ce
que j'ai fait et d'avoir prouvé à mes
enfants à mes petits enfants qu'il était
important d'avoir confiance en soi et de
pouvoir avancer
voilà merci
je tiens à le dire qui a dit que
l'argent ne faisait pas le bonheur